des jeux de lumière des décors fleuris
fantaisies pour un palais un objectif
vous transportez dans le monde des
contes de fées ce nouveau genre
littéraire trouve son essence à la fin
du 17e et début du 18e siècle dans la
société aristocratique pour cela
plusieurs scènes sont installées au
Château de Rambouillet ce coup pour le
merveilleux qui se développe à la fin du
17e et bien va s'accompagner de
recherche sur l'illusion un travail sur
les miroirs comment est-ce qu'on va
positionner les miroirs dans les salles
pour nous permettre d'avoir cette
impression que le décor s'étend à
l'infini tout ça ce sont des éléments
qu'on retrouve dans les dés dans les
décors décrits dans les contes de fées
pour découvrir cette exposition il vous
faudra environ 45 minutes pour déambuler
dans les 5 pièces aménagées pour
l'occasion les décors qui font écho à
l'histoire du château de Rambouillet
puisqu'il s'agit d'un appartement
aménagé justement dans cette première
moitié du XVIIIe siècle où se développe
l'art rococo et vous pourrez découvrir
dans cet appartement de merveilleuses
boiseries rocailles depuis début
novembre dans le château cette
scénographie destinée un public familial
pour ses fêtes de fin d'année j'invite
vraiment les familles à venir et à
découvrir avec les enfants ces
différents décors qui rappellera
justement tous ces contes de fées qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui parfaitement et qui
sont issus de cette période du 17 ci fin
de la fin du 17e et du début du 18e
siècle l'exposition est à découvrir
jusqu'au 6 mars pour un tarif de 9,50 €
avec un seul mot d'ordre laissez libre
cours à son imagination